what did you want before Miami
I just wanted to escape my life
[Music]
do you like bartending it's not really
what I do what is it that you really
really
but then
you came along and gave me these
unexpected
magical moment
that made me remember who I really was
[Music]
let's go
why are you in London I'm gonna put on a
show at this famous theater
disconnected we can wake them up with a
wave of passion they've never felt
before
hell yeah without further Ado I give you
the Visionary artist Magic Mike
no one's believed in me like your mom
has
so what's the show about it's the same
more will she marry For Love or Money so
what does she pick
Ed the real question is why does she
feel like she has to choose what it
sounds to me she just needs to let go
[Music]
and some good
maybe that as well
[Music]
you're not shutting me down not this
time you're so good at this I'm not
gonna just let us give up on it I want
every woman that walks into this theater
to feel that a woman can have whatever
she wants whatever she wants
foreign
what's your name Kim
let you out for the warning right